Dominican deadlift the premise of a ddl
a bit like a BBL is to make the area
bigger more girth more length in the
actual area is that with erection or
flaccid both I've seen it done in the
wrong way people have injected Vaseline
into the area there was a guy that had
done that and we had to remove that from
him what state was the penises he was in
stage of chronic pain couldn't have sex
having a pain in the area was having a
lot of infections due to it he'd done it
based on seeing research online you know
these DIY sites did he need one he
didn't have like a micro penis okay but
is it average this is such a funny
conversation
the true Geordie podcast